today we have invited magnus carson down
to the good night here in oslo what
magnus doesn't know is that we've
prepared a very difficult opening quiz
for him
now there are roughly 1500 chess
openings out there in the world
i could probably name a few hundred of
them
but uh we're gonna test magnus carlsen
let's see how many unusual chess
openings he can name and recognize
okay i'm gonna start you off with one
that you definitely know
okay so e4 g6
d4 and
knight f6
yeah this one has several names like the
norwegian rat or the north sea defense
yeah i think maybe north sea defense is
the correct official name yeah
i know you've played this one as well on
the champions chess tour
on b4 i think official name is maybe the
sokolsky uh also known as the randy time
yeah i don't remember why it's called
the iranians like i think i've read the
story it's not a bad move by the way the
myth goes at least that tatakova was at
the bronx zoo in new york and he had a
conversation with an orangutan called
susan about what he should play and move
on and
apparently she told him he should play
one before this one
i'm not sure whether you know the name
of but it might be possible to work it
out
uh so
one knight a3 if you think of the
chemical oh the nitrogen opening or what
n a is not nitrogen
n a is not nitrogen uh
oh it's nothing
sodium
sodium
sodium attack i'm sure that's not
different in norwegian it was right in
norwegian okay this one
i think a lot of the viewers might
recognize as well from the champions
chess tour
and
this position
what and manos goes
don't do
does it have another name than the
double bond cloud or like say no the
funny thing though is like this position
is great white it's like
much much better
so this one might be tricky
[Music]
d5 and knight c3
i mean i have no idea it's like kind of
grumpy attack but not a real grumpy
attack the name of the opening was
coined by a famous grand prix attack
player
yeah it's called the toilet variation
because apparently mark came up with it
while he was
in the toilet oh he also mentioned if
you checkmate using the toilet variation
then that's a royal flush
yes
yeah and
so on
i mean it's the start of a hippo setup
but it's not a hippo it's not a hedgehog
it's a hip hog
you can also use it for the type of
movement it's like kind of
if someone is kind of
the creepy crawly the creepy crawling
the creepy crawly defense very bad
opening
i'm learning though this is good for uh
mostly
i don't know for for trivia i guess
okay i can already tell you i probably
don't know okay
so this position threatening checkmate
yeah black flocks and white gives up a
porn
could be anything yeah i think i see
somebody play like this i don't know why
on earth they would this one is named
after the
a part of the anatomy of an animal
like the donkey scrotum
cut
very close actually horse's ass
the monkey's fun the monkey's bum
it's another english chess player and he
said if this works then he's a monkey's
bum
but it doesn't work it doesn't work
that's the problem
can i see a
for which opening we can play one bullet
game with one of the options
i'll beat you with the creepy crawly
okay
[Music]
you start to play play normally after
you play rubbish for the first few moves
but you're losing on time what are you
doing
[Music]
this is beautiful actually take it
drive you away i'm going to win on time
hopefully unless i get mated very soon
where's the wind where's the wind
how is there no wind i'm still safe
completely safe
so close okay
one for the creeper crawler